So with regards to AB testing
I know that startups and
websites will often do this.
How do you know when to AB test and
when not to?
>> Good question.
I don't have a baseline number for
you in terms of traffic for your app or
your website.
But my advice to new founders is always,
when you're just getting started,
don't waste your time.
I think AB testing is
extremely powerful,
it's a great way to look at large groups
of customers or visitors at once.
It's awesome.
But when you're just getting started,
you don't have large
groups of customers.
You've got a trickle at best.
And your job at that point as
a founder is to understand
those customers the best
you possibly can.
And there's no substitute
in that situation for
sitting down in front of somebody and
having a conversation, watching them
use your product, understanding
where you're falling short.
And so
I always advise founders at that stage,
spend your time picking up the phone,
rather than setting up AB testing.
Wait for AB testing when you've
got a bit of traction and
you want to start making data
driven decisions that way.
>> So really, essentially it's important
to be close to your user at all times.
>> I couldn't say that
enough as a founder.
Yeah.
>> And
tell me a little bit more about
how you go about AB testing and
sort of you know what's your
decision behind running the AB test?
What do you make sure
you want to AB test?
What should you avoid AB testing?
>> So first of all there
are a set of features which have
contradictory kind of
appeal to the user base.
So for example, a lot of people on lock
screen wouldn't want to have the time
and weather on the right side, but
they want to have it on the left side.
Or they want to have a quick
access to the left and
the unlock button on the right.
So all these things
have to be AB tested,
we have to understand
how the user behaves.
And not just that, for example,
we wanted to disable this home button.
And make sure that the lock
screen has a complete
pattern protection lock kind of thing.
But we did not do it because
in our AB testing results,
we found out that a lot of people did
not want the home button to be disabled.
>> Oh.
>> So how
do we disable it without knowing?
We would have spent a lot of
resource wasting building it and
which not many people
would appreciate our user.
>> Wow.
Yeah.
>> So, that way we go
through all the AB testing.
>> So, in that case it sounds like you
avoided going down a path that you
didn't want to go.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Great.